il dritto faccio pagare di lato faccio
pagare facesse perché aveva i capelli
lasciano così per un po di giorni poi
vediamo cosa si riesce a fare se il
decespugliatore funziona direi che
possiamo cominciare signori al governo i
bar ei mai cappelli no scherzo siamo sex
isles che un altro horror un altro oltre
ma sta già parlato troppo di questo
argomento cambiamo è perché sempre le
stesse cose dico basta
io dico basta basta siamo su excite che
questo gioco horror che mi avete
consigliato il mio game e mi piacciono
questi giochi e ricchi di trama che ti
spiegano tutto proprio tutto tutto
qualcuno è nato il personaggio come si
chiama perché finito lì proprio tutto ti
spiegano bei ragazzi siamo qui siamo qui
questa non è camera mia il letto e lo
stesso però a posso c'è un posto per
avere un tic ma ti spiega c'è una cosa
di comandi come si aprono e come uso le
mie mani ammesso che ho le mani si
perfetto dove si è perché c'è la barra
del mio cuore che non è quella del mio
cuore sono quest'ora sarebbe molto più
veloce
giochiamo al gioco del prova indovinare
che cosa succede secondo me adesso
compare qualcosa nel corridoio così no è
che stan cialis come sono scesi qualche
strano ragazzi però non sono dispiegate
dove sono io hai bisogno della chiave
per aprire questa perché tutte le altre
no nelle altre invece basta tirare le
testate si aprono
vabbè andiamo di sotto mi piace un sacco
sto gioco mi ispira da morire tra
l'altro effetto sonoro this land airmen
del 2012
ho visto e dell'acea e un attimo ci sei
passato adesso si è già riuscito a
macchiare pavimento hanno un pulisco io
e pulisce ciccio che è bravo a pulire
tutto stato io non sono stato il retour
au store
no back up the job tranquilli tranquilli
non vi disperate che il video esce anche
domani questi che urlano di unità cardin
start card system to open di snor ho
capito tutto quello che ho appena detto
giuro
allora se servono delle carte
io non ce le ho forse c'è da lui mi
scusi amica delle carte che mi servono
non credo che ce l'abbia lui però
secondo ma posso prendere vita al
machete che sempre che un machete mi
sembra più un coltello dello chef tony
questo non posso prendere mai figure
pressione a faccia lì allora non è vero
primo ragazzo segnatevi il giorno perché
primo horror nella storia primo dove
trovi un coltello e lo puoi prendere
incredibile come l'equipaggio tra
l'altro che non eccolo ma dai ma che
storia grazie zio cioè ti offrirei una
birra ma non so quanto non secono me non
lo regge dal col
c'era la porta prima di su gara chiusa
con la chiave questa invece chiusa con
la tessera dobbiamo trovare una tessera
che immagino sia di sopra credo è tu
prova ad uscire lì che ti affetto la
famiglia ma dico ci guarda ma c'è
un'altra tessera di un'idea cardo due
tessere devo trovare prima o poi le
trovo una blu e una rossa permesso e
dove la porta eccola ecco ecco a blu
ma fioriscono esso qualsiasi cosa che mi
sarebbe spuntato qualcuno da dietro ma
non è successo
grazie videogioco sei troppo buono che
si scorda qua ho trovato un manubrio di
monopattino c'è meno sembra quello
sabato 1 card system slot 2 elevator
energy card sino a eccolo dove mettere
il caso del manubrio del mano partino
perfetto tutto c'è un ascensore
se però stai calmo poi schiacciarli col
dito i baffi va bene mi piace sto gioco
perché mentre cordi ti fa vedere quanto
ti rimane di corsa cosa che dovrebbero
mettere in tutti i fottuti sim i giochi
horror ma non c'è neanche in mezzo card
system fatto let's go
max che buio messo all at allegria
non ho mai visto una sedia più brutta ma
ce ne vuole poi sono impegnati a farla
così brutta ma seriamente semi ecco per
mi sembra troppo bello e caricata se mi
spara i semini quindi non siamo proprio
sull salvi però che bella anche la
lampada la simpatica qualcuno vuole
assaggiare un po di biondi semi perché
io ce l'ho e non può realizzarsi mi ci
vedo contro il primo nemico propria
sfera alberelli che poi sta roba c'è
scritto 220 volt cioè se potevo prendere
una scorsa da un secondo all'altro per
ove energico highly venture energie
ristori ok quindi posso usare le leve
tor può sparare sui tasti
ci è andato in automatico va bene perché
lo sapeva usare le mani giusto problema
e o nei giochi horror specialmente in
questo permesso comunque sono contento
che siano sempre tutte ambientazioni
molto molto simpatiche divertenti
permesso stato che potrei sposarmi così
però l'utilità di questa cosa non so se
è eccessiva quindi lasciamo perdere
se mi passano davanti gli sparo se busi
ti sparo lo stesso chiusa grazie a dio
lui la madonna permesso a quanta gente è
che figo inter e non sarebbe una brutta
a casa se la radesi al suolo
in quel caso sarebbe bello se non
eravamo in un ospedale prima fu demonio
beccati sti se mi tocca esti gassman
chiesto tizio salve
c'è una chiave qua la prendo
c'è tanto c'è l'effetto sonoro che
cresce il tipo è fermo
vabbè è chuck bass back dei settimo
fanno così ma allo steri forse un po
male fanno però dovessi morire tutto e
citando da 6 ore però potevi morire un
po più calmo lo so che sono pignolo però
le cose vanno fatte bene se non ho
capito cos'era sei stato simpatico per
quel poco che ti ho conosciuto va bene
dove tra l'altro dove era nascosto su
tizio che uscito da niente
gli avanti ragazzi ora queste chiusa
così ho trovato chiave di chiara chiave
una chiave a caso vanno avanti bello sta
pianta sono contento che fa schifo il
posto però la pianta è curata bene
tra l'altro ci sono dei modi per
recuperare vita in sto gioco qualcosa
del genere
non ho idea io apre questa no apre
questa non apre questa c'è un'alta ecco
qua dicono ci sono andato prima chi che
bussa da un'ora e mezza o questa qui
permesso non vorresti assaggiare mi
sempre che sono veramente disgustosi
cioè il tipo di prima agli assaggiati
non gli è piaciuto per niente
mi stai ferma teoria dovrei tenerla
aperta perché se questa si sveglia e un
problema c'è una tessera rossa li
arancione che sarebbe la prima porta di
prima
stai ferma stai ferma da siamo si è
piaciuto
più semplice del previsto va bene e
torno indietro che ci dessero ancione
già che siamo in un ospedale posso
curarmi che il tipo prima mi ha toccato
il sedere e sto sanguinando per un
qualche strano motivo no ma è normale
continuiamo a sanguinare ai portate che
si apra le porte un controllo sempre
detto perché mica go c'era questo dietro
sta piacere ad una chiazza di sangue per
terra io veramente non potevo farne a
meno di svolta demonstration dei mix tra
di noi no non può finire così ti ammazzo
ti sparo tutti dei semi in faccia
porco demonio morto ieri perché perché
perché cosa mira cosa mi rappresentava
cosa perché mi fai giocare una roba dove
io non mi rifiuto
c'è chi giura vabbè io e quindi ragazzi
visto che il gioco è durato poco
voglio regalarvi un po di politica
non era un po i video che dite
eccolo qua mouse simulator b 2.71 perché
hanno fatto un sacco di versioni print
art ok ok perfetto
io so che bisogno c'è né se non è che
voleva allungare il video in modo
simpatico e semplicemente credo che
questo sia un gioco che vale vale
tantissimi soldi
prendete di tutti di l'ibrido tutti a
sta rispondendo pian piano è in
dissolvenza va bene neanche il miglior
film di spielberg e così hai finito un
bel gioco va bene allora facciamo che ci
sono dei tassi per farla ppi e dei tasti
per fare della popolare do che c'è non
li ho visti però i prodotti che andiamo
avanti
porca vacca esseri umani schifosi via
c'è una grafica prima che si sono un
topo non può non potrei apprezzare al
meglio le tue doti quest ancora seguendo
porca vacca scappa roditore di delle
palle via via via fargliela pensare a
lei fi e la presa festa la festa festa
sono furbi questi umani sono non
sarebbero la specie dominante ti vedo il
culo nell'ombra via via via via via
nell'angolino nell'angolino del pertugio
ma ci entri come citra sa benissimo come
andiamo a dal gatto la gatto porca vacca
schifosi umani vi conquisteranno un
giorno ve lo dico io a succhiare non
pensavo funzione è stato bellissimo
perché non lo aspettano mai funzionato
allora rivali sti 3 euro ragazzi direi
che possiamo concludere qui il gioco è
stato ben sapete che faccio youtuber dal
2012 e figo per me trovare contenuti
come questi ragazzi e spero che il video
vi sia piaciuto però vi sia piaciuto più
quello di prima
forse la più bella non lo so ragazzi e
sono sempre contento di far parte della
grande community di youtube portandovi
questa roba
quindi ragazzi spero mi dispiace
mi piace che se non siete per i siti
iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo visto da ragazzi
[Musica]